the GameSpot co-op stage we are here
with some WWE superstars first we have
the former NXT champion current number
one contender for the WWE Universal
Champion going head-to-head this July at
great balls of fire against Brock Lesnar
the on and only Samoa Joe very good to
be here very good to be here thank you
thank you Matt who else Oh sitting right
next to me he is a part of one of the
longest reigning at tag-team champions
of the world remember the new day host
up up up down down and the sunder you'll
be facing the Usos
yes as money in the back bunny the bank
give it up for Xavier woods everybody
yeah also got second place in the street
fighter tournament today
[Applause]
very very nice well welcome to e3 guys
thank you so much for being here we have
a whole hour with you to talk about
video games wrestling and anime all the
things you want to talk about all the
things you guys love if you guys didn't
know there are also huge gamers which I
love I saw you guys on up up down down
talking about video games and rap music
and all the things that you are super
into and so let's talk about what kind
of games you saw at e3 2017 what did you
see
so uh the main thing that we did
yesterday was Call of Duty World War 2
and Joe's huge world you buff absolutely
huge World War 2 bug very excited about
the game and as we expressed you know
its its boots on the ground and we put
the jetpacks down so that's a solo run
it from me butter from me and Team
Deathmatch now you got stay on the
ground we'll find you so I'm very
excited about yeah it's really cool
being able to use a shovel in trench
warfare as soon as somebody comes down
the corner you just use a shovel to like
stab them in the face and not that it's
like and I want to feel real cuz that's
terrifying for what yeah but it feels
real quick it's awesome yeah you never
knew you wanted to hit something the
head with a shovel until you played this
game yeah really light I mean I know I
did but I
it's this different it is different if
they play together on a team or oh no no
we played against each other yeah it's
it's a it's a good friendly rivalry it
is it is what but who won who won his
team won he didn't win all right I
wanted to because difference I got six
kills with a shovel yeah I just went
over and caught a lot of buckshot for me
I did so just blindly charging him
head-on with a shovel like he's got a
shotgun so it didn't work out too many
times but I got one that was awesome all
right I also heard that you played some
Dragon Ball fighters yes talk about that
did you get to play I did we both did so
good let's talk about this game this is
my surprise of e3 my favorite game of e3
yeah but only because I'm such a huge
Dragon Ball fan I know you are too so
who did you play as what do you think of
the game so with the demo you can play
as Goku Vegeta Gohan majin buu cell and
Frieza
you get those six character in trunks
two trunks in it I think maybe no no no
okay aspectek oh you couldn't man uh but
it's cool cause it kind of feels like a
mix between like NBC and guilty gear but
it's kind of like the Dragon Ball
fighting game that we always wanted you
can pick whatever character you want to
once the actual game drops uh and it
looks amazing it does it looks just like
you're watching the old yeah it looks
pretty much like a seamless episode of
the animation yeah which is you know
kind of a thing that you see in a lot of
games this year but I think the biggest
things is the fighting system was really
revamped it feels more like a kind of
like an actual tournament fighter as
opposed to something kind of dash around
and shoot missiles at yeah have these
Close Encounters so I mean it was it was
really really slick really polished
surprised me cuz I'm not I'm not the
biggest Dragonball Z game fan but uh
this game I definitely does yeah did you
play us I think I think that Vegeta
majin buu in the cell that was my squad
yeah oh and after you select your
character you can change the colors to
which I know I'm like a geek for
customization stuff like that so like
you can make cell like all white with
the dots like it's it's so it's so sick
if I like to his point I like the
old-school Dragon Ball games like it's a
Super Nintendo and all that stuff like
your dashing around like it's cool and
fun but as far as playing it and like an
eSports setting like it didn't have that
kind of feel to it to us at least but
this one like I feel like we're gonna
see this at Evo yeah
like the year that it drops Alisa get
has evoked potential so which characters
from Dragonball would you like to see in
the game definitely Crillon yes he's my
favorite Dragon Ball character
cuz people don't think about this like
nothing happens if Crillon doesn't die
yep
if Crillon doesn't make that sacrifice
nobody turns super saiyan and the earth
is destroyed so he's to me is the most
important character in the show
clapper Crillon everyone I mean I like
to piccolo just go okay you know just
because he's constantly disinterested
after something happened to fellow let's
see him like wins bad so his Curlin also
your favorite Dragon Ball character in
general yes because of those three same
reasons and who's your favorite Dragon
Ball character uh I mean although we did
have a big argument whether it was
Vegeta or the cell saga which was a
little bit but uh I think I think Vegeta
as a character okay yeah I kind of dig
him I can relate to him yeah I'm gonna
say so have you watched Dragon Ball
super have either of you seen it so I'm
so far behind an anime I'm like on
Episode five yeah I know your big anime
fans yes
but finally I'm being able to get into
it because uh we have a guy on the NXT
roster Brendan Williams great black
otaku check him out and he's like our
anime expert he's like dude so there's
like this like the 76 episode is super
oh my god no no no no I'm on like
episode 4 he's like wow you've had so
much time it's like and I also haven't
like really watched the season 2 of
attack on Titan yet you know what it's
ok it's just so there's so much to watch
that's my wish to watch I love I love
beerus though yes
so like beerus yeah he's my jam
especially so in the movie when you see
him and he slaps Bulma and the Vegeta
turns up oh this mess up so I'm excited
to see what happens you out the story
yes so I'm Way behind so a bunch of
stuff just got spoiled for me
I mean I guess I'll catch up eventually
sorry I'm so sorry let's go guys of
video games all right what else did you
see at e3 we just took a look at destiny
- nice I know you're a big destiny fan
oh yeah I mean I dig destiny um you know
play through it you know got got raid
partners and stuff like that and it
looked great I think a lot more variety
in the enemies of the play style and I
mean it looks pretty ambitious it's
pretty cool we got to check it out on
console and PC and we put in played
single-player PC was gorgeous like the
environment you're just like and it just
kind of kind of playing like the the
opening kind of scenario it was uh it
felt really big it felt like you know
definitely like a triple a title
something that you expect to see so I
mean they did a really good job with it
what feature are you most excited about
in destiny - that they've changed since
s anyone um so we didn't get too much
into the features yeah that the I mean
basically we played some crucible and
then we play through the first the
single-player kind of the initial intro
campaign but so I mean mostly it was
just kind of the feel of the game it
felt a lot tighter I mean you know that
obviously you know Bungie does a real
good job when it comes to you know
putting together the feel of their games
and especially the weapon feel and stuff
but this one definitely felt like it's
just just all together felt like a big
improvement over the first which is
saying something cuz the first was was
was pretty spectacular so it was a lot
of fun yeah and I know one of the things
that we were talking about like the past
few days is we know there's definitely a
place for people who are reporting on
games saying oh you know it runs at 30
frames per second 60 frames per second
what does this do what does that do and
for us we're just focused on is the game
fun yeah like does it feel like a fun
game and after we walked out like sc2
feels fun so it's like something that I
want to play more I was still dropping
like frames shade though so 4k 60 frames
a second is 4k and it runs that there's
you know like I just upgraded all my
house with all the 4k stuff so it's like
I'm very demanding on my spec so you
know I'm always like so dirty
locked up for all the consoles okay what
school are you planning on playing
destiny to with do you have a designated
I have I have a few friends that I play
destiny with and
usually that group and occasionally like
for raids we got a kind of outsource to
find a few other people here and there
you know obviously Big Show he's you I
mean he's Big Show by far is the biggest
destiny fan in Beijing without a doubt
one thing that people don't really know
about him so we kind of dove into that
on up up down down my youtube channel
subscribe if you haven't already uh uh
his love for destiny and a lot of times
I feel like people put us as sports
entertainers in a certain box so you
LARP for a living this is what you do
that's who you are
um but once you hear Big Show talking
about destiny it's like the most
passionate conversation that you ever
hear anyone have and as soon as he finds
out that you like destiny that you've
played it oh man
I'm my light level is this I got this
we're gonna raids here look like my
light is this and it like whoa like I
play it but like it's like a religion to
him he loves it and it's very cool to
see someone from our world who's got
that sort of love and passion for game
and he was here earlier this week and
was able to work on them with the panel
and everything so it's it's nice to be
able to kind of bridge the world
together and he also has like no respect
for you if you play a Titan like I don't
know what leg yes means like oh you play
and then once again he overwhelmed me
with information I was like I play but
you play bro you're about this is it all
so he was like yeah you know I got a
Titan and what Oh guys are scum of the
earth alright and yeah I don't think
he's still got I mean he would be in my
play group I hope you know really got
over it her Savior you also uh I'm
noticing this fine metal around your
neck uh so you obviously played some
Street Fighter this weekend guess I did
this week tell us where we got that
metal those this morning
there's a street fighter tournament
blazed through it got to the finals and
then was handled and I was nothing I
could do but luckily the second place
metal is still gold so I still feel like
a winner you are a jewel ations thanks
good job good job
who's your main street fighter 5
birdie-birdie well if we're talking
Tekken King oh okay let's go a second
you guys can see me right there if you
want this work yeah we
you have a second devastation here so
you can play after this so I know you
are also super into Tekken yes I am
and who do you mean I'm Steve Fox guy
Steve Fox all all arms yeah well I just
it's just that extra level of
embarrassment like you know I'm not even
kicking man like it's really about the
trash talk after what's better Oh me no
no no so we have to find out oh well we
will oh yeah sorry that's already in the
works the skill runs deep all right okay
get tombstone you can get giant swung I
got empower bombs for days I got you
cheddar Bob don't worry about it he
laughs his hands
what's Hummel how much longer we got to
we can go a while all right you got him
you gotta sign for everyone here and
take photos okay yeah but anyway so
we've already talked about some games at
e3 so math you want to talk about some
wrestling let's let's chat about some
wrestling would you guys like to see
some wrestling show now you have you've
made the jump from raw to Smackdown new
day is finally there I'm very excited
sure lots of people out there are as
well uh for you who was you know with
the people that you want to work with
the most on Smackdown with in a tag-team
division uh brie Xango yep so uh well
I've been really close with Tyler breeze
like for years all throughout
developmental we've just been like this
so being able to see him grow in this
capacity with with Fandango and see
their like whole sexy cop thing take off
it's hilarious and that's kind of our
wheelhouse is being the fun entertaining
comedy thing so the fact that like we
can play off of them and we have like
that sort of like relationship bond with
each other like in real life it makes it
so much easier to do in front of a
camera and out in the ring but then also
like the Usos they're just amazing
talents and they're finally getting an
opportunity to break out and show like
who they really are because like the
what you see on TV like the way that
they act and the way they cut their
problems like that's them like those
guys are hysterical but if something
happens like they will get hood and it's
nice to see that finally come out on
screen if people are kind of getting the
getting the taste of it but honestly all
the teams with the colognes
we got American Alfa ascention like our
goal as as the new day
I guess essentially uh is not just to
build ourselves up because we are
obsessed and love tag-team wrestling and
want to make sure that there is a
spotlight put on the division and so I
think on Raw you kind of saw once we at
the time and then I think it was it was
Claudio or sorry Cesaro and uh TJ we're
tag team and all the teams kind of came
together and built it up and it went
from like on the pre-show to mania to
like having a spot on the show at Manian
like that's what it's all about so we're
excited to be able to be at Smackdown
and hopefully band together with all the
other teams and do that again we be
appearing on more fashion files oh yes
when all is done 100% fashion files to
me is the best thing on WWE right now
it's hysterical i Joe you were the you
were the number one contender for the
Universal Championship congratulations
on that so going into Extreme Rules
you're in this this group with just your
all the top guys at raw how did it feel
going into that match um you know to be
honest with you it's uh it's one of
those times where you know you have such
a gathering of talent I mean everybody
involved in that match is probably you
you would consider one of the one of the
greatest performers in the world and
going into it I was pretty confident
felt good about the whole thing and I
and uh I think that night we produce
something special and a you know y'all
come tipped in my favor and I was very
happy that it did so it was a it was an
opportunity that I very much look
forward to going into it so going and
going to great balls of fire you know
how are you feeling about that that
match I can't wait I can't wait I can't
wait for great balls of fire
and it's the truth you know Brock
Lesnar's a guy that I've lied before
before I ever stepped foot into the WWE
you know I've made a career and I've
made a reputation of taking on the
toughest competitors in the world from
any and every company Brock Lesnar was
on that short list of people who have
yet to come across especially on such a
big stage and when the opportunity was
presented to me I jumped in full force
and I'm very much looking forward to our
encounter and for being the next
Universal champion you definitely say
this is a dream match for you then is
that we could say this is a dream match
for you then absolutely without a shadow
of a doubt it's a dream match in a dream
scenario because you know if I'm gonna
become champion I want to take it from
the very best in the world and that
man's Brock Lesnar and I will take it
from me anymore Coquina crutches for
Paul Heyman uh you know hey listen I
have a lot of respect for Paul
tremendous advocate tremendous
individual and I've stated this before
you know Brock's on a man who sends
messages through words it's great as an
orator as Brock Lesnar I mean as Paul
Heyman is Brock Lesnar he's very uh he's
very action based man when he decided
not to show up that week he was sending
me a message that he didn't sweat me and
then he sent Paul Heyman forward he says
Paul go tell him about his impending
doom and it's it's mind games a strategy
Paul he's a master of it and I
understand this so when somebody sends a
messenger like that you send the
messenger back with a message except
mine was just as physical as Brock
Lesnar's is and if Paul Heyman decides
that he wants to uh if Paul Heyman
decides that you know he would like to
send me another message I'll be more
than happy to stick a note in his pocket
and send him back to Brock is there any
routine or rituals that you have to kind
of uh you know coming out of the curtain
going onto the stage to kind of get into
that Samoa Joe mindset they know uh I'm
very unapproachable uh coming through
the curtain
you know I kind of go through a kind of
a series of just kind of martial arts
once I've done four years um you know
and then it's it's it's I call it waking
up the limbs so it's a very very
aggressive mean slaps to the legs arms
thighs face chin and most guys are
sitting there back there going what the
hell's wrong with this camp and uh yep
I've even had Vince go Jesus you know uh
and then you know I walked through the
curtain his games on yeah there's
nothing up there well it's interesting
because uh for me my guys our warm-up is
very different from Joe's one least you
tell we're we're like dancing and
hopping around and we see Joe across the
hallway beating himself like mercilessly
I guess it's like as if if he can beat
himself like this if somebody else does
it's not gonna hurt it's bad but yeah
pretty much the theory Bach yeah if
you've never like woken somebody up too
early and they're just real mad at you
they don't talk to you like that's how
Joe is right before he goes out you just
you kind of give him a wide breadth as
he's come down the hallway but he's in
the zone yeah the new day has been a
part of some of my my favorite segments
in WWE in years in years for for you
guys what actually for you what has been
one of your favorite segments or most
memorable moment um I'd probably say
okay so there's two and I don't know how
to like say one's better than the other
um but one would be when we got to go
back and forth on the mic with the rock
because the rock has his style that is
that Attitude Era style and we have our
like a pg-13 style and so both being in
their own kind of wheelhouses clashing
on microphones like that's a dream to me
because he obviously like one of the
best promo guys ever if not the best so
as soon as they told us oh you get to do
this today and it's like what like a
[ __ ] to get people's elbow and like
what
it's so sick this is amazing um that
like coupled with taking a stunner
at WrestleMania mind-blowing um but uh
segment wise probably and I segments
match as well probably the moment that
we had with the Wyatts battleground
where ray was trying to take my mind
from me because that was something that
I don't know we like stories within
stories and so to be able to tell that
story to the point where everyone
understood it without words necessarily
was just very big moment for me so I
don't know if it's something that
resonates with everybody like in the
crowd like for me it was a big personal
win well it's very different from the
new days you know normal routine you
guys went very serious and very dark and
then yeah it turned out really really
well yeah so the new day is done a
little bit of cosplay you've done some
Dragon Ball inspired outfit some Final
Fantasy inspired outfits any chance
we're gonna get more Oh 100% yeah that's
like being able to mix cosplay and and
wrestling is the best thing ever because
it's two things that I love there's an
event called Dragon Con that happens in
Atlanta like every Labor Day weekend and
I'm 10 years deep there and we've been
cosplaying the entire time so the fact
that I could say oh this is what we do
like on the weekends with our friends
but now like we're getting paid to do it
on television it's like it's not what is
going on and then also to I feel like
there is a there's something that people
have missed out on in I guess TV culture
I guess in not having people in that
market to say like hey this is a
complete culture with people that are
alive and awesome and they do great
things and I feel like being a what a
cosplay brings more eyes to it they go
oh what is this all about then they see
conventions like III they see stuff like
MoMA con they see people at San Diego
comic-con and they're much more
accepting of it because they understand
like there's a force and there's tons of
people behind it yeah um what kind of
cosplay would you like to do you have
any ideas I don't know like
top-of-the-line stuff probably if I
could get some sort of like sweet static
shock cosplay in but like coming down
like Shawn Michaels did at WrestleMania
and on the zipline but we have it like
like electricity so it looks like I'm
flying through the air like the trash
can lid that's that's probably confident
like all this make this happen I think I
have to admit I'd love to see you
sliding out electrified
I've got a cosplay suggestion could you
come the new day do final fight just
like I see biggie as Mike Haggar we're
good I were trying to get him to do uh
Final Fantasy 7 so I want to see him as
Barrett yes yes how did those Final
Fantasy and Dragon Ball cosplays come
about so the Dragon Ball cosplays we
were just thinking like this is
WrestleMania it's huge we got to do
something crazy and uh you don't know
what's gonna happen the next day like
something could happen and you're not
wrestling anymore so we try to live
every segment like it's like the last
thing we're gonna do so WrestleMania
we're like you know what let's dress up
as something that's not necessarily
wrestling esque
and long story short I was told one time
that I wasn't allowed to wear that
Vegeta over 9000 shirt oh really yeah
like oh you know you can't wear that we
don't we don't have that cartoon like in
our repertoire it's on on the network
it's not something that we could use and
so that year at WrestleMania
I see Ronda Rousey you get into the ring
and what does she have on that over 9000
vaquita shirt so I live and thrive off
of this thing called spite and people
telling me that I can't do things you
know just the truth tastes delicious and
so at that moment I said I'm not gonna
wear a Dragon Ball shirt I'm just going
to be a Dragon Ball character and so
that day I was like returning my hair
into Vegeta
we got say an armor let's do this and so
it was like the best feeling in the
world but the funniest part of that
story to me is the fact that once we
came in the back we did all the stuff we
were in the ring with Shawn Michaels
Stone Cold Steve Austin Mick Foley and
it's amazing like amalgamation of
characters from back in the day and now
and as soon as we get through the
curtain it's not like me Kofi and ear
saying this like special moment like all
that was awesome guys congratulations
I'm glad we did this
Kofi comes to me he goes why did you
have a tail and I didn't the first thing
you said to me it's like alright cool
that's how I know I'm messing with the
right guys yeah yeah let's go back to up
up down down let's talk about that
channel so how did it come to be so I
wanted to have a channel kind of like
what they do on like the Food Network
where they're traveling a different
countries and stuff and trying the food
but
as we travel around the country I always
find different arcade bars and I always
end up talking to the owners acting in
their stories because I eventually want
to have an arcade bar of my own in
Atlanta hum so I figured why don't you
take a camera talk to these people and
then everyone will know oh when you're
in Portland go to ground control when
you're in Atlanta go to battle & Brew
there when you're in Brooklyn go to
Barcade and they weren't too keen on the
idea at the time because we hadn't doubt
but we didn't dive into the realm of
video games at that point and so someone
in the office side want to make a
YouTube channel so we kind of melded the
ideas together and said let's just try
to make a gaming channel and I guess
what so two years ago we came to e3 we
said hey we're finally getting things
underway and told everybody what kind of
videos we were gonna make and filmed a
few and we're like oh I hope this works
and luckily uh Vince McMahon and Hunter
were really behind it and they said you
know what greenlight doors open do your
thing if it works cool if not cool
but luckily people enjoy it and it's
been working people eyes liked it
driving Thanks but I think the cool
aspect of it is that it is the mix of
being able to play games within getting
actual personalities from the guys so
like you said the episode with Joe
talked about games talked about hip hop
and you get a little bit more insight in
the people you're watching on on
television on the shows yeah that's
awesome so are we gonna see any
injustice - oh definitely yeah
definitely all right did a little bit of
a live stream and sometimes
so before I start live streaming or
filming I'll get online and play for a
little bit and I test the waters so if I
lose too many times in a row I just
don't film that day good oh I can't get
look look too bad Joe Joe when you
mention injustice to Joe nodded like
yeah oh yeah all right so you're in on
the bag the surprise man Lady Justice -
yeah you want it that's the problem my
power girl will put you in the ground
oh you don't man Romero's nasty see who
else would you get involved in a
tournament um let's see so we're still
playing UFC - a lot that was like a
sleeper for me I I played the first ones
I'm like when they had on like Dreamcast
it's like okay this is fun uh but then
once this one came around and a bunch of
guys in the locker room started playing
it like that became like a staple and it
is one of the most fun multiplayer games
I've ever played in my life at this
point um so guys that we get to play
like most of the cruiserweights play
video games so we get like rich Swan in
there a lot the Usos left a game Brees
loves to game obviously Kofi and II then
we get like Bailey likes to get in
Sascha likes to get in so it's it's like
a wide array of people because it's one
of those things you're just hanging out
just like you were when you were kids
like you're in somebody's basement just
playing whatever like oh I might not be
good at this but I'm having a good time
with with my boys
you know nice what would you like to
play one up up down down mmm suggestions
yeah yeah well it's kind of like digging
up stuff that we don't so there was a
game that like was really big - is k1
kickboxing for PlayStation very very
underrated title we played a ton in
Japan it became a big money game
especially amongst the American and the
Japanese wrestlers and they haven't done
a game since but if we could dig dig up
a copy somewhere somehow I got to like
play that find one
what's the next for a book down down
what's next um - just try to keep
growing so my biggest thing is doing
collaborations with just generally
people that are on YouTube internet
personalities to try to figure out what
they do and what they think works for
them in their audience and just building
more bridges between wrestling and
things that wrestling may not
necessarily attach to so maybe doing
like this co-op stage right yeah like
five years ago we would have never
thought that we'd be sitting here
talking about video games for an hour
now like everybody understands there is
this Venn diagram of wrestling fans and
gaming fans and there's that second in
the middle and I feel like it just gets
growing daily until they're just gonna
be on the same plane because I mean the
way that we explain it a lot when I'm
talking to a bunch of my friends is this
is stuff that I got made fun of for when
I was growing up and even watching
wrestling so like past 13 years old like
what you still watch wrestling you
didn't grow into that yet it's like no
cuz it's amazing they're telling these
stories of good versus evil through
physicality like we liken ourselves to
two artists because we wrestle on a
canvas we just use our fists and feet'
ours paintbrushes but we're creating an
art um and I think video games are the
same exact thing it's visual it's audio
there's stories and so I feel like it's
the same exact crowd both who got made
fun of both who just
want to get left alone and do their own
big and so we meld those together
and just become an even stronger alright
let's talk about the gaming community so
I saw you at kind of funny live 3 and I
saw you win as Street Fighter so who
else would you like to take in the
gaming community that's free fighter mm
yeah play Cisco free fire shall see
Cisco um I don't know there's so many
people especially just like Pro Street
Fighter players because getting just
destroyed in games is something that I
enjoy in a weird way because you learn
so much especially you learn yeah you
win all the time you're not learning it
if you're the best guy in the room you
did to change room he's gonna learn
today - oh sure that you hear that mom
uh but yeah honestly any of the pro
gamers that are out there and as we
bounce around at different events like
hopefully we'll be able to get out to
Evo a little bit this year that's like a
please hopefully um but yeah honestly
anybody cuz like as far as like being
good at these games I'm like down here
so everybody's above so I want to play
with anybody and everybody nice Joe what
are you currently playing uh so we have
this discussion earlier so when you get
off the road and like you know you've
been out there stuff like there's games
and maybe necessarily like you wouldn't
think you play but they're just easy to
get into so I mean I love overwatch I
play a ton of that um you know you know
obviously a lot of the first person
shooters battlefield one Call of Duty
but like you have to get amped up to
play them otherwise you can get Punk'd
you know so it's like so when I get home
I find myself like I'm not really pumped
up play overwatch but like I've been
playing Ghost Recon wildlands a ton and
I'm on this leg kick to like 100% it and
it's like you know I start on my gosh I
play like a half hour and then like two
hours later I'm like damn man I'm
looking for scoped attachments for and
how did you get into video games uh I
think from a kid early on I think you
know and honestly I don't think it's
such a rare thing I mean when I speak to
you know most people my generation and
and going forward you know video games
are part of our of our culture of our
life I think just as much as movies and
television shows we're part of like
previous generations culture
so yeah I mean I remember getting my
first Nintendo Entertainment System and
that was my personal first video game
system and I think I've had every video
game system since and damn near every
game so it's a you know it's a it
becomes an addiction and obsession but
it's one that has brought great joy to
my life and I've enjoyed a lot and not
continue to do you know and I will
continue to do probably in the future as
I mean he came he came to the locker
room day with a VR setup in like two
hours later I had once lived in my house
and all set up by the time I got home so
yeah I mean I just it's something that
is easy for me to kind of unwind after
you've had a real stressful week and
Anna fits both physically and mentally
out in the road to be able to get home
get in front of a game and kind of a
transport yourself out into a different
world for a little bit it's it's a it's
a big help for this lifestyle so is the
game that you're most looking forward to
this year destiny - it's one of them I
actually a playing Call of Duty today
like I said I'm a huge war bore - but I
love call of duty - and in the previous
iteration I mean I love modern warfare
my interest started to wane but you just
pick it up because College is just
something you pick up every year but
playing called a tooth I've been playing
the new Call of Duty now it really
really got me excited hyped up for so
I'm looking forward to that awesome
tell us your backstory with video games
how'd you get into it um so same thing
with the NES first gaming system but uh
my mom always tells a story when people
talk about games with her I was
terrified to play Super Mario because
like little kid me when you died in the
game you died in real life so I putted
like nothing to do with it
so my sister would always play and
eventually she coaxed me into playing
and I was just very socially awkward
just super quiet kid but my mom noticed
that when I would play video games with
other kids actually only time I'd really
talked to them and so she would set up
like playdates for me to play Nintendo
with kids and she noticed like oh you
know he's like gaining verbal skills
he's not so shy
and so becoming friends with those kids
to video games didn't going to school
those kids essentially taught me how to
talk to other kids so video games
essentially broke me out of my shell and
so like Jose said it's a way to unwind
but it's like my happy place forever
especially in that real awkward time of
like middle school to high school
that awkward transition of being a weird
age teenager Sega Saturn was like my so
I would turn off all the lights and I
had a purple lava lamp that would be
going and I would play like clockwork
night too
and so like with the wee hours of the
morning taking the ark would you light a
candle to oh my god
play some George Michael filled it but
yeah it's just always been a way to wind
down whether school was frustrating or
there's just like life stress so even in
adulthood now like it's a way for you to
have that escape and just go to a
different place and play and in
adulthood now I've gotten into MMO so
I'm playing Final Fantasy 14 like it's
my job because it's amazing and there's
so many different kinds of people that
play so like there's times where I'm
playing with people who are in Japan
Australia England like Barbados and is
making friends all around the world
through video games yeah so that's what
it's always been to me it's been a
social contract for me and I know that
nowadays there's so many people and
think of video games rot your brain kids
you need to be outside playing the Sun
it's like I think all things in
moderation but I don't think the video
games have that negative effect I think
they have such a huge positive effect
because they're allowing you to branch
out the social also you can turn it into
a career I wish I had more videos with
me was telling me please get off the
video game I think another thing too is
that like and we talked about this
before is like we're from like the
arcade generation yeah yeah and I think
the death of the arcade is probably one
of the saddest things when it comes to
video games because no being down there
throwing your $20 in the quarter machine
and it was a meeting place a social
gathering place for so many of my
friends kind of growing up you know
before you're 18 and you're out doing
the fun stuff like I remember the arcade
was kind of like the hot spot to be at
where everybody kind of met up and had a
lot of fun so you know I I definitely
that's one thing that I would love to
see come back I mean with the bar kid
that's cool but yeah I think just the
arcade in general I think is just a cool
social construct that I'd love to see
like kind of come back into prominence
which classic games did you spend the
most quarters on always like brawlers
and like an x-men Golden Axe you know
stuff like that you know your hair let
me know a turtle yeah turtles in time of
course you know like Street Fighter and
Mortal
that the first couple runs of that I
mean it was just uh it was always kind
of amazing thing to put you quarter up
and you know know that you had next yep
you want to take some Twitter questions
let's uh yeah let's do some Twitter
questions all right
Oh questions in last week the first ones
from Dan Rev V and uh yes what game do
you believe you've put the most time in
over the course of your lives
Joe Oh fallout for easy Oh like it's
actually recorded like you know I went
on Steam i went on Steam like a couple
like maybe two weeks ago and I look now
it's like damn and like that's a lot of
my life like what was the time at uh
let's just say it was in the months same
question uh Mario Kart Double Dash easy
that to me like there's no game better
than Double Dash it's like the most
replayable game ever made are you still
playing it oh god yes yes I I legit have
my my we hooked up to my TV right now
because old school we you can still play
the game view games on it dude and it's
it's the best good answers alright next
Twitter question is from I'm Marsh
Watson and he said what's your favorite
meal
Korean barbecue yakiniku um it's just
it's a great yacht with friends you have
a grill I see yeah let's meet chill have
a coke we uh have a couple adult
beverages and hangout time for everybody
mine would be a stuffed crust pizza with
pepperoni and bacon
yeah slathered in sweet baby Ray's honey
barbecue sauce Wow all right all right
the lodge is there next question uh this
one is a Xavier
what are you playing some more switch
games plates which constantly I mean I
think it's referring to up up down up up
down down so things are in the works
possibly coming soon uh but switch is
very intense in the locker room I can I
can say that we've got a lot of people
who have gotten into it because of our
schedules traveling all the time being
able to take that console with you on an
airplane and now that we have Street
Fighter 2 out on it like it's gone to
like the next level and so now I'm on
Smackdown now but Joe still on Raw he
was giving me stories about some guys
that are on the red side who just are
into their switches like nobody's
business so hopefully they find a spot
in the arena and it's just like that's
where they are that's what they're gonna
be for a while they put in their time on
the switz yeah alright next question we
have from marshal AJ Samoa Joe do you
have full confidence you'll beat Brock
at great balls of fire
yes and I don't know why anybody would I
don't know I think maybe it's gonna oh
man
like I'm gonna I'm a wit brats ass like
I'll see why things any different yeah
there's no real other way to say that
yeah yeah llama wit Brock Lesnar's ass
[Applause]
my next question uh from Marquis candy
are you looking forward to playing
destiny too and checking out new areas
in the game yes absolutely yeah yeah
after we played the the the solo stuff
on the computer like it's like we're
saying earlier it's it's gorgeous
it's awesome and the stuff that you see
in the beginning I don't know if we're
allowed to like say it and spoil things
for anybody but like the fact that there
are these new areas that are coming
that's always fun in new games and
destiny being such a strong title and
was so amazing with the first one came
out and all the expansions like the fact
that we've got the second one whole new
world of stuff going on whole new story
is like super psyched to see everything
yeah and I think like the the most space
in general is always something is kind
of evolving getting better and better
and like you know now you have the
second height iteration of it it's like
you want that you know you think they're
gonna correct the things that they did
in the first one and make the second one
even better so I mean I think got the
Box gonna be a better experience nice
question from max he says what was your
first video game and what is your
favorite game of all time yeah you can
start requestion
the first game Super Mario and then
favorite game will go back double -
alright easy
yeah first game I hope Super Mario I
think yeah the one with the duck hunting
it too though yeah yeah yeah we always
duck if your bubble car choose yeah
hey I actually had to get those
separated okay I think they give me like
gyromite with the robot that didn't work
in my favorite game um I mean it's
probably read and we've talked about
this probably Final Fantasy 6 like yeah
I saw that you guys were agro we have to
argue about it see we did have an
argument about it that means the best
seven you're wrong out strife man next
questions for Molly's Samoa Joe what is
your favorite Nintendo game of all time
uh I just mentioned it right there yeah
I think that's a much hands down I mean
I mean from it was what I think was the
first like game experience I had that
the story was very riveting and I was
like really like engrossing and I dug it
was I think it was like the first kind
of masterpiece experience that I had
with video games were before you're just
kind of playing for ice core but that
was totally invested in it and then and
very much about it and had to complete
everything and get the best ending and
do it the right way so that'd be it from
ajs for Xavier woods rank your top 5
Zelda games and how did you like breath
of the wild no pressure
first for me is easy and I don't know if
this is popular or not but ocarina of
time my first time ok why do you act
like that's like controversial that's
not even close no because I'm Karina
Todd they remade it like 70 million
times we're so good I've gotten in like
heated arguments and almost like ended
friendships a guy can fight because like
I have like a glass ocarina in my past
that real is overlaid yeah and that's
why I got this on my arm the ocarina of
time is my jam um let's see
and then probably Majora's Mask um uh is
this from 1 to 5 yeah 1 to 5 link to the
past
yep yep good one then I'll say breath of
the wild ok for it and then
hmm in the first one gold cartridge
all right well cartridge first yeah yeah
but yeah Ocarina of Time is definitely
like and I think it's to Joe's point of
like playing your first like masterpiece
game that for me was it because again
like being scared of video games at the
beginning and its kind of playing them
casually uh that was the first time I
was able to sink my teeth into something
there's character slider just fall in
love with and then having the ocarina
being able to like have a horse that
runs around like Epona like it's it's
amazing so I think that's something that
definitely sticks with you over time so
you not only have the nostalgia feels
but like this is one of the games that
like changes the course of your gaming
life and says okay this is what I'm
gonna be doing for the rest of my life
and that's what did it for me you have a
favorite Zelda game I think I'm pretty
close to that I probably would swap like
a Link to the Past a little bit higher
up but yeah I mean I think it's pretty
I'm pretty close to where he's that well
and the second part of that question was
what do you think of breath of the wild
oh I think about the wall it's fantastic
we're actually talking we've got a guy
with us Brian we call him our dad
because he makes sure we make it every
way we need to go um you could yeah we
asked him he asked me uh oh you know how
many hearts do you have now I'm like
oats six he's like well you're like
almost know what the game was like yeah
I use all my points for stamina I'm like
for stamina we'll see like why just I
can climb wherever I want at any time I
could wherever I want
he's like you're you're playing this
wrong you need to need to reevaluate the
way you're doing this uh but yeah it's
it's it's really fun
at first though the weapon system was
like super frustrating to me but then
once you get a hang of it like oh you
just hold like seven weapons at a time
you're good but you have a torch and
they have a stick that breaks when you
use it twice but then you have this
sword that hits for like 65 damage so I
think once once I got used to it I got
deeper in the story it really started to
like hit home and mean a lot more to me
okay so you're at e3 2017 is this your
second third either 33 for me alright so
how does this one compare to the last
two um
it's weird because like I said at the
first e3 we just came in we're like oh
we're starting a gaming channel hey guys
were like on the scene like please
accept us we're okay we promise to now
like we're like on stage with you
talking about like
all this stuff games and wrestling and
the mix that has been occurring for the
past like I guess like three years now
um so it's very cool to see the
progression in the you like thought baby
that I had so long ago and the fact that
now we like we have Joe out here with us
it's it's just awesome and it feels good
and the fact that like you guys are
receptive to it and super supportive
like I can't tell you like what that
means to me as someone who's like
putting their like life and soul into
something so thank you trolley goes
awesome so your game of the show do you
have one so we haven't gotten to play a
lot of stuff that I've been super hyped
about but I think besides black Dragon
Ball fighters like I really really want
to get hands on spider-man yeah it was
like watching the trailer and everything
and then when everything ended and then
you go back and then you see Miles
Morales yep I was in my hotel room
losing my mind we're all screaming
unless I get a cool like with the story
like from the comic book where something
happens and then he takes over like or
is it just it's actually him that he
likes do all that then come down and
take pictures like what's going to
happen so um I'm really excited about
that and then the Detroit troit become
human yes yes that was fun to me and I'm
very Indian the story based games uh so
like until dawn like I played about like
eight times and then watched more people
play through it so like any game that
has that kind of choose your own story
but kind of futility on though yeah I
really pump to see that and then like we
were talking about anthem yep - like
yeah looks like the most more than
gorgeous game ever frostbite is like
amazing do you think that the destiny
comparisons are fair uh I mean until I
play a game honestly I hate to make
comparisons I think we do it too much in
general I think oh that's just destiny
for this or that's just you know call it
to be that and I think every game kind
of adds own feel and and I know
developers work very very hard to
differentiate their IP from another so I
think it's almost irresponsible to kind
of make that comparison and especially
after it kind of being involved in the
development process with other games
throughout my career and just knowing
like how hard these guys are working to
make it something different you you hate
to be like oh yeah you're just a clone
of this so I mean that's why we
definitely want to see little bit more
of it get our hands on it
and you know see for ourselves but if it
is you know that's 4/6 anthem the game
that you're most excited about that you
heard about at e3 2017 I think so for me
I think so just because uh just I know
my the people that I play with it that
we do I do co-op with like they were
really into it and I mean that you know
that that whole experience is very
predicated on the the people that you
surround yourself with so they're about
it you something about it nice all right
Matt any questions or do you bring up
like a system with you when you go on
the road I know a savior obviously does
I don't have to because there's
literally eight yeah different people at
any time who have a system on them so
it's it's really it's not a necessity I
mean less you want to play in your room
alone but I mean there's there's always
a system set up in the locker room
there's always a system set up somewhere
on in the building at any point in time
or if he's filming up up down down
there's usually you know all kinds of
cool gadgets going around so it's a
you're never at a loss for a system when
you're on the road who are you playing
with the most usually during the week uh
so I have a buddy of mine who I play
with actually runs a great charity pops
for patients if you're a pop collector
and you want to donate and help out some
kids please check them out pause
patience org but a guy named Randy Leeds
good good buddy of mine and he's kind of
like one of my main guys that I play
with he also helped me kind of do some
minister ating then when I used to run a
twitch channel running my twitch channel
and stuff when I had time so that in and
I have just kind of general friends that
have known for years that have kind of
just been in my Xbox friends list and I
mean have them don't even know that I'm
a wrestler which is hilarious to me cuz
you know you were talking and then like
you know a little quip will come up and
they'll just be like oh what were you
doing in Singapore yesterday no nothing
shut up get back to the raid yeah living
a secret life yeah so do you guys play a
lot of games together we did before
I know Smackdown what is your favorite
game to play together mm-hmm if I had to
say we've never played this before
together but I know that it would be our
favorite game to play together Def Jam
Vendetta yeah no doubt oh yes
my wrestling questions I was gonna say
uh can we get Samoa Joe on jumpscares uh
you know I'm in yes to see who doesn't
jump you have a tournament for that I
just I just like he understands and
sometimes I just have violent reactions
yeah so yes so when like when we put him
in the VR I've made sure like step way
back yeah just cuz you don't want to get
punched in the face if you look at his
hands
they're heavy and they hurt shown to the
camera uh so what I love your entrance
music it's one of my it says so much
about you know who you are when you get
in the ring how did that all come
together so a really kind of a crazy
process so initially when I when I had
come in we had talked about interest
music and the guys at CFO I mean they're
they're incredible they really really
are Amina just have an incredible talent
for producing music and and really in a
timely fashion which is for an artist is
something unparalleled and I'd come in
and you know work working with NXT 100
asked me said you know hey listen give
me some examples of music that you like
or stuff that you use in the past and I
I just named off a few things if you you
know several different especially when
in my during my indie run several
different songs and music one of them
said the mama said knock you out you
know and but I've always used the the
Godzilla the classical toe a Godzilla
intro which was kind of like sampled
used in a song called Simon Says but
Pharoahe Monch
and so I'd mentioned that they had
produced the first song for me and you
know I came out to it and then I
remember I came backstage and and you
know he asked me as like I you feeling
that you like that I said it's alright
I'm not really you know not super duper
about it and he goes well you know he's
like we want to get it right let's
change it and so we had a big call and
you know like I said I started supplying
these samples and music and then I
remember the first time they heard the
Simon Says beat they were just like this
is the one and they said well what do
you want to sound like I said I want to
sound like Godzilla kick it over Tokyo
and he goes
give it give us a few days and then days
later my current music came out and we
were very very happy with it so let's
talk about some other entertainment so
we also we cover a wrestling on gamespot
universe but we also cover movies TV
comics so tell us about what TV shows
you guys are watching or super into mmm
just started watching a Handmaid's Tale
oh I heard my god depressing it is
intense so uh I have a thing where if
there's a show coming out then they have
a book I'll do audiobooks cuz like run
planes all the time or the gym and I've
been able to just multitask and listen
to those books so ran through the book
and I started watching the show like if
you don't watch it watch it it is it is
like come home and relax type of show
it's like it's like I need to like put
my brain into something that's super
intensive like after the credits roll
like have a discussion about it type of
show that in like black mirror I love
black mirror yeah I'm on the black lever
back right yeah what was your favorite
black mirror episode I think the the
social media one yeah so deliciously I
wanna yeah it's too real like I actually
know people like that so it was just
inside I was just laughing hysterically
yeah I think yeah I was my favorite
black America yeah did you see the one
that was about video games yes yeah yes
yeah my mind not to spoil anything for
anybody uh watch that one though yeah
it's amazing
it's really good all right what shows
are you and T besides black mirror uh
black mirror uh I really I really
enjoyed Westworld Rada
it was you know it kind of took him by
surprise I didn't go into with like a
lot of high expectations so I think that
really helped the viewing and other
people you know people also world-beater
show it's the greatest ever that's great
um Game of Thrones yeah I don't think
that's like a big surprise but like and
it was cool I got to work on to do voice
voiceover work on the telltale Game and
it was just a really cool experience you
know to see the process and kind of see
this alternate story in that universe
and I mean and and I you know like I
said I've become a very big youtube head
man like I dig shows a lot of series
that are on there
and a lot of them on Vice I like a lot
of my stuff that's people to really
quick you mentioned your involvement in
video games so do you have any insight
into WWE 2k 18 we know that it's gonna
be absolutely amazing
all right yeah just be sure you're ready
to check it out obviously at a later
date more information will be coming out
but as always with our yearly game try
to make sure that people love it nice
what's your involvement like when you're
in like WWE 2k 17 and games in the past
so for me obviously do it stuff with the
gaming channel and uh is making sure
people know about it and they know how
to play it and we have tournaments and
stuff and that like I said it's not
gonna go that people are enjoying it
that's the biggest thing like we talked
about we want to make sure my video game
is fun but with the w/e 2k experience we
want to make sure that you're being able
to feel what it's like to like have that
entrance or to build your own entrance
or like if you were a sports entertainer
like what would you look like well
interest music what you have how the
lights work so that was always like the
coolest thing for me playing those like
old-school n64 wrestling games like
building yourself and having this whole
persona but now you're able to like draw
your own designs on shirts like there's
people that are out there like let's say
someone was have like a new set of gear
at like a SummerSlam or something well
you'll see on Twitter the next day
someone has drawn it and color corrected
and put the little designs on it's like
how are you doing this this is amazing
stroke it so it's just cool that we have
a community that is a one like well
versed in the stuff that we're putting
out but then also have such a love for
it that they're able to do those things
and have such a good time playing it so
it's like it's out to the community for
for being awesome that's awesome that's
awesome so let's go back to you've
mentioned Game of Thrones who do you
want to see in the Iron Throne
that's a great question yeah very good
question
get ready I'm gonna ask uh I caught in a
malicious way I kind of like the way
it's worked out so far you know
seriously up there she's doing pretty
good she's doing pretty nice but I mean
uh I think I if they if they're long way
that I think they're headed and then you
know you never know except they will
deviate I mean they said that um you
know we'll see how things work out with
Jon Snow you know yeah zavier Khaleesi
yeah coming to Westeros I have this like
love for her she's incredible uh and
we're actually talking about this the
other day like is it is it hurt it's
like we saw her like turnin Terminator
movie it's like oh she's awesome like in
Game of Thrones I don't know what she's
doing like with the character but like
immediately as soon as you see her like
you're like sucked into that character
like succeed please on your the best
mother of dragons you came on a fire
what this is unreal so like I'm I'm a
huge Khaleesi guy you think we'll see
any more stark reunions with the kids
you hoping for it I don't know I don't
know I Game of Thrones is one of those
shows where you can be so attached to a
character that's been in there since
episode one then all of a sudden all
like him and his whole family died don't
get attached it's like now we have to
start over
we're like where are you so deep what if
what happened so like even like I don't
if you guys like read the books or
anything but like so much stuff happens
and you just lose characters for like
why wasn't happening don't get attached
yeah it's much like with like the red
wedding when that happens you just like
yeah
feelings yeah favorite game of Thrones
character uh all the hound hound yeah
good choice good choice
how about you it changes yeah so like at
first uh I would I would say uh Jon
Stark and then it switched you um what's
it sister's name
Aria so we switch the Aria start but
then is switched to the hound and then
off the hound in like to Brienne so like
its legit every a couple of episodes
like I think a solid contender at all
times is Tyrion so I if I had one Tyrion
Lannister that's fair this is my dude
yeah so how about movies what's the best
movie you've seen this year pop stars
from last year
no because pop stars came out this shops
what The Lonely Island movie I'm sorry
just last year I think it's also the
movie this year too though if you want
as you can tell we don't get a chance
yeah okay any move yeah I saw it this
year I did see it this year there you go
cut the black Rangers in it for no
reason like doing a snapchat um it's
really weird like the best cameo ever um
okay so then this year uh I'm okay I'm a
cyclops guy okay so I like always
denounced Wolverine but I saw Logan that
movie's unbelievable Logan is fantastic
so good as soon as you see her come out
with the claws and she's bouncing around
like a bouncy ball
it's like Merkin dudes I'm like yep I've
been this is fantastic but uh yeah it's
it does such a good job of telling a
story
I lied not the best movie I've seen this
year get out
yes yes give me the key give me the key
the movie is a masterpiece yes because
it speaks so much to real life if you've
been in that situation but but you know
that there's this underlying fear like
my art says you're not you know on your
neighborhood my neighborhood no there's
just like underlying fear in the fact
that they were able to capitalize on
that like small thing for into like a
horror movie it's like we've been there
before you can kinda relate so Nana know
what we just don't know it's a touch
hard on here for us Joe favorite movie
I've seen this uh so I haven't seen a
ton this year cuz obviously it's just
it's been a lot of work but I really dug
John wick to John wick it was fun good
if you liked the first of a second roll
yeah absolutely
yeah which one was better first or
second uh kind of like the first a
little bit better to be object yeah okay
okay all right so what movie are you
looking forward to are you big into
marvel at all mm-hmm
are you looking forward to the next Thor
movie well for me yeah Black Panther yes
that trailer is incredible see like just
so that I actually refused to watch the
trailer really I want to be just coming
clean okay I've been so hyped about as
soon as you saw him in the Avengers
movie I just like yeah um so I just saw
like a picture of it he's like in his
throne would you fella tear somebody
else so that and movies that like
haven't been announced or may not ever
happen back to static shock I want a
static shock movies all right and I
wouldn't be mad at you boy got cast just
might happen make it happen what movie
are you looking forward to Joe uh
so none cuz uh I cannot reiterate enough
I have like zero time lately he's
tremendously busy does up up down down
but uh kind of on this latest run I have
had like zero time to catch any media
and I'm like a classic like like I said
when we see movies it's usually on like
an international flight because that's
when uh everything's just out of theater
so yeah I don't know I haven't had a
chance release it down and say that I'm
really finding let's close out with what
message do you have to video game fans
and people that want against wrestling
people that wanted to get into video
games hmm you love video games
you're not alone because there's an
entire culture that stands behind you
there's an entire culture of people who
have been made fun of and haven't pushed
in the dirt for loving these things we
are now adults and we are non stages
like this we are now wrestling and part
of the WWE we are now in music we are
now in football we are now in soccer we
are now everywhere
so this know that if you're a child
who's going through some things and
video games are your only retreat we've
been there and we got you
alright Joe any last words for your fans
and expounding on what he said we play
video games to be able to transport us
to fantastic worlds and scenarios that
we could never do in real life and if
you enjoy these scenarios if you enjoy
these these tragedies these dramas these
great accomplishments these great
heights that I guarantee that if you
tune in and watch the art form that we
call professional wrestling you will see
very much the same thing and experience
very much the same thing so please join
us in both realms and we hope that you
do all right thank you guys so much for
being here we're gonna throw it back to
the GameSpot demo stage Thank You Xavier
thank you so much Joe see you guys later
[Music]
[Applause]